hey guys I'm Ryan right hi I'm Laurie
gah
we're gonna watch this video today
called Batman can't stop thinking about
sex okay from CollegeHumor
I love College Humor a great channel I'm
interested to see what Batman's take on
sexes I'm already coming back I needed
but escape yeah but he is not the child
I why hey Talia al Ghul here to finish
my father's work oh we totally @j yes I
know you're early
all right boy three times it was all a
cruel employ to gain your confidence
that was it cruel boy Savio Frater when
the mission is a bad law act is all good
I agree and he was out there a second
are you [ __ ] okay okay Bruce action up
okay let's get back you must be
wondering how we came to this moment mr.
Wayne
you like it
my father liked a lot my father never
accepted bane hello dad by the way
anytime ed showered that day and I fight
crime in a rubber suit really feels in
the flavor
Oh little changes my father only saw a
monster who could not be tamed
you changed my monster oh just shut up
okay
what's your bail to other places huh
in an order that would surprise you
enough all right that's it
there's my Lagos freaking cool I am
overall TAC dog hey Ronnie
we need use any protection and I offered
[ __ ] no no no Bane it's fine
these words will be his last last words
were spitting right now Oh a bomb is
about to blow Gotham and I
how'd you I stamped you first with my
Jake
just to clarify gotta breathe through a
crab it's not the first time one of us
to shove nine hard inches up into
somebody's ribs yeah when I get it to
her enough soon you will feel the fire
of 12 million souls you failed so what
you're saying is by touching that red
spot in just the right way there's an
explosion you know good I do the
alphabet hey it's real quick bees were
bad it's clear as I get it I get it you
don't have to show me I found it I the
world Trey's detective yes how does it
feel bad something hot penetrate your
body Oh sobbing I mean I can think of
like tad off of that okay Oh sex jokes
aside I am losing quite a bit of blood
my movie it all right [ __ ] this I'm just
a bloke on from now goodbye hey are you
crying right now
geez your space is all wet like my gosh
at the beginning any back you a shoelace
what the bottom you get Gordon away to
block my signal no matter you bought
yourself 11 minutes you should blow
yourself
these are other pair of panties I
totally hippies for you when you're in
the John a lot of memory you want to
know which one of these tubes you smell
well now you have
she'd cry funny stuff it was decent that
was not the best CollegeHumor video that
I've seen no from the videos that I seen
by CollegeHumor I had really high hopes
for this video it starts off with a fun
premise
I mean first off the setup I like this
does look a lot like The Dark Knight
Rises like the production value the guy
doing Batman's voice sounds very
accurate easing we got like the face
lifting down to but face lip thing ya
know it was a funny premise at first you
know like this Batman who's like just
obsessed with sex and rubbing it and rub
it in it wait as it progressed I was
like yeah I get that it source to be a
one joke premise I get that it's
supposed to be like that's what makes it
funny is one job yeah pretty quick I
feel like it could have been like a
minute shorter a lot of the best jokes
just got it's like yeah we get it
yeah you're you're naming all different
kinds of different puns just keep
running interface but other than that
yeah did get old pretty fast the actors
were decent I'm not a big fan of
parodies when when they break character
dialog like when they just start
sounding like regular dudes like
seriously oh Jesus when they start
talking like that I get pulled out even
more I like it when they stay in
character the whole time so the best
moments from that were when they were
still in character like the Batman dude
stayed in character for most of it I
feel like our faces during it like oh it
started were like yeah then like slowly
our smiles are just like
we were just deadpan I mean college
humor is really good at everybody are
really good I don't I'm just gonna say
like wow yeah I don't know college humor
has and as far as like you better
that's what I was trying to say I know I
took me that's that's a good sentence
hahaha Dark Knight Rises parodies go
I've seen like a shit-ton and this is
one of the better ones and I got a lot
of them don't make me laugh so as far as
like a parody of that film which is like
2 years old so I'm probably really late
on this video I still thought it was
pretty you know it's it's decent good
enough it's good enough thanks for
telling me that video was out if you
knew the channel you can subscribe to
the real rejects Lauren GOG just passed
a thousand subscribers you can check out
her channel check it out as soon as you
can because it's cool looking at hot
asian chicks right yeah that's the only
reason why he has me on this channel I
need an Asian girl you lease your
nondiscriminatory yeah I try to show
them not racist but I hate having a
variety of ethnicities on the channel do
a black person I recently got a black
here we go I'm not racist
Oh working on the NPAC I'm at I'm
Filipino of Veronica's uh the Hispanic
one you're like Jim one Sally's red head
true yeah you got that's that's a big
minority man Samantha was blonde and now
she's redhead to Alyssa's brunette
Italian yeah and Dan is a guy he's not
razor nerd Oh white guy he's are white
pale friend Monsieur mud shed I have
seen Ryan's but sad face my sad face I
think I deserve a shout-out for having
to go through that what the [ __ ] are you
talking about awesome Channel keep it up
also I love penguins good for you on the
pain one thing I think I deserve a
shout-out for seeing your bed yeah
everything everyone deserves seeing my
ass if you haven't seen my ass or two
videos you can see it on Magic Mike
double XL trailer review and April
Fool's
video check them out see both left yeah
you can get some pubic hair one of those
so Monsieur much yeah this is about you
now my ass oh that's lame you don't have
any photos your latest post said I hate
most people of this Facebook feeling
cool dude I think you're trying too hard
to be cool right it's not cool to hate
man it's not cool to hate it's not cool
to say you're cool once you say you're
cool and you're not cool anymore yeah
yeah unless you're like Ryan Gosling or
Ryan Wright
or Lauren God we can establish that
we're cool we're pretty cool what have
you done
we have a camera recording while we're
watching a video sounds pretty damn cool
that's cool